you have three babies on the way is that
true or false well yeah
the stork is on the way
this is what i said if you thought the
numbers are uh put up in 2021 with it
first a refresher of canon's kids by the
numbers
the 41 year old already fathered seven
children with four women three were born
last year
baby mama number five bree tac seen out
yesterday is expecting nick's eighth
child
abby de la rosa the mom to nearly
one-year-old twins zion and zillion
recently announced she is pregnant and
as for this little experiment my
therapist says i should be celibate
maybe take a break take five on the lip
service podcast nick revealed his
celibacy journey ended last december
after the tragic passing of
five-month-old son zen i got depressed
like with the loss of my son and stuff
right before christmas i start like
crazy now to more baby news
country star sam hunt revealed his wife
hannah lee fowler gave birth to their
first child a daughter named lucy liu
the couple's happy news comes weeks
after fowler's request to call off their
divorce was signed off by a judge it's
important to stop and sit still and
reflect from time to time in the initial
divorce filing fowler alleged hunt
engaged in quote inappropriate marital
conduct our source tells et quote sam
has been putting the work in and making
sure that hannah trusts him
[Music]